two things to watch out for for
everybody who's listening number one
watch out for delusion in confidence
building too many people go too far and
they go into that eighth place trophy
delusional place and then kids don't
believe you number two you can't be the
only source of positive reinforcement
the other part that made me was ringing
doorbells and having 81 people say no
kid I don't want you to wash my car and
having six of them say yes kid I do want
you to wash my car for five dollars I
think what also made me was standing on
a lemonade stand months of my life from
6 to 13 and watching 99.9 percent of the
cars drive by my stand and not stop and
buy my lemonade I had a baseball card
table and I watched a hundred people
walk by and not want to buy anything
from me even though I had good stickers
and good cards all those no's became
enjoyable it's the yes that acts as the
evidence though it's the person coming
along in the 100 buying the lemonade
that makes young Gary or young me go do
you know I can sell lemonade 100